♪
With us, God,
when we walk through the valley of the shadow of death,
and when we stand on the mountaintop of joy,
God, we find you near.
We find you close to us.
In the breath of our lungs,
in the beat of our heart,
in our skin, God,
you are woven in and throughout,
and we find you present in all things, God.
I ask for your comfort where we're hurting.
I ask for the bone of reconciliation
where things in our world are broken
and in need of saving, God.
Would we find you there?
It's in your name that we ask all these things, God.
Thank you guys for worshiping with us,
and I just want to introduce to you guys Stephanie Acuna.
She is going to be doing our reading tonight before Brett's message.
So without further ado, thank you, Stephanie,
for sharing this time with us, and I'm going to pass it to you.
Thank you very much, and thank you for that beautiful music.
Tonight our reading is going to be from the book of Luke,
chapter 22, verses 47 through 53.
This is about when Jesus was arrested.
While he was still speaking, a crowd came up,
and the man who was called Judas, one of the 12, was leading them.
He approached Jesus to kiss him,
but Jesus asked him, Judas, are you betraying the son of man with a kiss?
When Jesus' followers saw what was going to happen, they said,
Lord, should we strike with our swords?
And one of them struck the servant of the high priest,
cutting off his right ear.
But Jesus answered, no more of this.
And he touched the man's ear and healed him.
Then Jesus said to the chief priests,
the officers of the temple guard and the elders would come for him.
Am I leading a rebellion that you have come with swords and clubs?
Every day I was with you in the temple courts,
and you did not lay a hand on me.
But this is your hour when darkness reigns.
Thank you, Stephanie.
Well, good evening, everyone.
Grace and peace.
Welcome to the table.
And I'm just really, really grateful to be with you all.
And you may have also noticed that we have little comments popping up.
So Sarah Johns is serving as our hostess tonight,
and so she'll be also running kind of the official table Facebook account.
So if you see comments from the table, that will be Sarah.
And so thank you, Sarah, for jumping into that role.
We're trying to kind of create as much community as we can,
even with this medium that we have here.
So I'm grateful for folks like Sarah who jump in
and help us start to inch towards creating that.
So, all right.
We are, of course, in our series on the Gospel of Luke,
where we're walking really just kind of front to back right through this gospel.
And we are getting towards the end of the book.
In fact, next week will be our last message in this series.
But tonight, the title of my message is This Is Your Hour.
And our text is the one that Stephanie just read.
That's kind of our primary one, Luke 22, verses 47 through 53.
So I'm not going to reread that now,
but if you're listening to this later on the podcast or something,
you can go ahead and look that up and read it yourself.
So there's the line that just keeps sticking with me.
It's Jesus' closing line where he says,
This is your hour when darkness reigns.
And I think the reason I just can't get it out of my head,
I just keep returning to it,
is because I see him doing something that we in our culture kind of don't do well.
We raised on the power of positive thinking.
We who so often are just very tempted to turn a blind eye to the darkness in the world.
We who have trouble facing our own pain, like much less the pain of others.
We who would rather have the peace of a lie than the discomfort of a hard truth.
We who believe that if we just had enough faith,
well then no bad things would ever happen to us or anyone else.
We who secretly are actually really struggling with the darkness in our own lives,
but we continue to project outwardly that everything's fine.
We who seem just bent on making people who are super sweet, nice Christians
instead of really honest, real, and willing to love even when it hurts Christians.
We who feel the need to defend God by pretending that there is no such thing as the darkness,
that the darkness really is only the light, seen from a different angle.
Yeah, we could really use Jesus' perspective on this,
because the truth is that he's having none of that.
And so he just kind of comes out and says it.
Like, yep, I mean, whatever you want to call it, like Satan, the demonic, evil,
this is your hour.
This is your battle.
This match goes to you.
Congrats. Live it up. Soak it up.
Hope you enjoy it.
And honestly, in a season that we're in right now of a pandemic,
of the ugliness of a police system that has sparred just for too long,
often used its power in corrupt ways,
in a world of men kneeling on other men's necks or shooting them in the back,
in a time where we all wonder how long we'll have a job
when our leaders seem intent on preserving their own image and ego
over the good of the country in that kind of world,
call me crazy, but I'm just going to go ahead and kind of admit,
like, well, crap, evil, this is your hour.
This is your battle.
This match goes to you.
Congrats. Live it up. Soak it up.
Hope you enjoy it.
Because, because it will not last.
Christ does not mince words about the evil in this world.
He does not try to spin stories about how the darkness is actually the light,
just seeing it from a different perspective.
No, he's very clear about the fallen, intragic nature of this world.
And that's why he can say, this is your hour when the darkness reigns.
I mean, even that word reigns.
But he can say that because the opening lines of chapter 24,
just two chapters later,
tell this story.
On the first day of the week, very early in the morning,
the women took the spices they had prepared and went to the tomb.
They found the stone rolled away from the tomb.
But when they entered, they did not find the body of the Lord Jesus.
While they were wondering about this,
suddenly two men in clothes that gleamed like lightning stood beside them.
In their fright, the women bowed down with their faces to the ground.
But the men said to them, why do you look for the living among the dead?
He is not here. He has risen.
Remember how he told you while he was still with you in Galilee,
the son of man must be delivered over to the hands of sinners,
be crucified, and on the third day be raised again.
Then they remembered his words.
Now, I'm thinking that's a really key part to forget.
Then, that's right, then they remembered his words.
Like, how could they forget that?
But you see, that's just it.
I think this is what suffering, pain, loss,
I mean, it's what Karen named earlier, grief.
This is what they do to us.
They tell us, they speak a word, and that word is forever.
The darkness says, whatever you're facing,
like your marriage falling apart is forever.
Your company falling apart is forever.
Your bank account dwindling forever.
Your depression and suicidal thoughts are forever.
Your nagging sense of failure is forever.
Your aching loneliness is forever.
The pandemic, the darkness says, is forever.
Police brutality is forever.
Even the raw wounds of coming out about your sexual orientation,
experiencing the rejection of others,
even your church community, this is an experience, of course,
that many in our community at the table have had.
The darkness says, that is forever.
But that is the great lie.
Which is why Jesus does not say, darkness, you win forever.
What he says is, this is your hour.
In other words, this is your time.
This is your season.
But just as at the beginning of all things,
God looked at the sea and said,
your boundary line is here, but no further.
Just as God looked at the mountains and said,
you will go this far, but not one inch more.
So Jesus says, this will be your hour.
Friday, crucifixion is your hour.
But Sunday, resurrection is my, is Christ's hour.
This will not last forever.
You see, the darkness is not the truest,
the most real thing about the world.
The light is the truest thing.
The God we've come to know in Jesus,
the one who is himself endless, self-giving, self-emptying love,
that he is the truest thing about the world.
In the beautiful words of Psalm 30 verse five,
this is maybe for some people their life verse.
Weeping may last for a night, but joy comes in the morning.
I think that's a word over you, table lights.
I don't know what you call y'all, friends of the table.
Let me read it over you again.
Weeping may last for a night, but joy comes in the morning.
What this is naming is that the weeping, the mourning, the grief is not forever.
And as I reflect on the stories of people of faith in the Bible,
this is a truth that I see just ring out again and again.
I think of Joseph thrown into a pit by his brothers.
You remember the story, only to later be falsely accused of a crime
and then thrown into prison.
I mean, talk about like the lowest of the low.
It's enough to be thrown into a pit by your brothers and then sold into slavery
and then add on top of that like insult to injury,
falsely accused of a crime, thrown into prison.
Like it's a mess.
And there he sits at midlife feeling like his life is, it's just over.
But it was not the case.
God had plans for Joseph.
And just a few years later,
he was second in command of the greatest empire in the known world.
His suffering was not forever.
I think of Hagar, purchased as a slave in Egypt, mistreated by her master Sarah,
eventually dismissed by the family,
and then unjustly driven into the wilderness with her young boy
with nothing more than a little food and a small container of water.
And, of course, those quickly run out.
And eventually the little boy begins to cry from dehydration and she knows this is it.
This is how it ends.
And so she puts him under a little bush, the text says,
and then she wanders a stone's throw away.
Why?
Because she cannot bear to watch her son die.
And the story goes that she began to sob.
Why?
Because she thought that moment was it.
It was forever.
It would be the thing that would define her.
But no.
An angel of the Lord appears and says,
Do not be afraid, for God has heard your little boy crying.
Lift him up.
Take him by the hand.
And then a promise.
For he will become a great nation.
And that's exactly what happened.
Hagar's suffering was not forever.
Or think of the apostle Paul, also known as Saul,
who earlier in his life was persecuting Christians,
watching as the first Christian martyr, Stephen, is stoned to death.
He's there overseeing the whole thing.
Because Paul, he is zealous for the ways of his forefathers.
He is ready to stand for the truth.
And so he travels around attempting to stamp out this Christian heresy
when suddenly on the road to Damascus a light shines around him
and a voice from heaven speaks to him saying,
Saul, Saul, why do you persecute me?
And he says, Who are you?
And the voice says, I am Jesus, who you persecute.
And in that moment, Paul realizes that he,
who was so zealous for God, has actually been fighting God.
That he who was so passionate for the ways of the Spirit
has been opposing the Holy Spirit.
In that God moment, it's so powerful that Paul literally falls off his horse
and when he opens up his eyes, he is completely blind.
And all the voice says is, Get up, go into the city,
and you will be told what to do.
And the story goes that he was led into the city,
and for three days he was blind, and he ate and drank nothing.
Is that the image of a happy person, a faith-filled person?
No.
Paul is in the darkness, both literally and figuratively.
And I'm sure he thought, what, it would be forever.
He probably assumed that this is it for me.
This is the end of my journey.
But little did he know that what looked like the end of his story
was actually the beginning of the best years of his life.
That he would recover his sight,
and in fact, he would then go on to write letters
that now make up two-thirds of the New Testament,
some of you holding your hands right now.
And to this day, those texts are read and reread and memorized
and cherished by billions of people all over the world.
And at the risk of putting us on the same level as Joseph, Hagar, and Paul,
I also think of some people at a little church in Sachse, Texas,
that launched out in November of 2019,
and then just four months later got blindsided by a pandemic
we haven't seen the likes of in a hundred years.
And now we're five and a half months into a quarantine,
and there's a lot of days that it looks really, really bleak out there.
We're tired, more than a little depressed.
It's hard right now.
But Jesus' words to us are,
the darkness will have its hour,
but morning is coming.
Resurrection is on its way.
So remain faithful, and you will look back years from now
and be astonished at what God will do in and through you in this season.
Let me pray for you.
Lord Jesus,
we receive this as your word to us.
God, I lift up every person who, just right now,
they're in a place where the darkness feels like forever,
or for those who have been there really recently.
And I speak over them your truth,
that it's not forever.
Darkness has its hour, but the light is coming.
Hope is coming.
Christ, your love is present and available to us,
and you can meet us even today.
We can have a taste of that resurrection life and hope and love even today.
And so, God, we receive it.
So where there's discouragement,
God, I pray hope.
Where there's a sense of despair,
I pray for community, connection, and love.
Where there's just a sense of distance from you, God,
may you close the gap.
May your spirit right now begin to speak to people.
Be near us, God.
Carry us.
And we trust that though the weeping lasts for a night,
God, your joy is coming.
In the powerful, life-changing resurrection name of Jesus, I pray.
Amen.
I will not break your heart, but dismiss your fears.
Get over your hill and see what you find there.
With grace in your heart and flowers in your hair,
there will come a time you'll see.
With no more tears in love,
I will not break your heart, but dismiss your fears.
Get over your hill and see what you find there.
With grace in your heart and flowers in your hair,
there will come a time you'll see.
With no more tears in love,
I will not break your heart, but dismiss your fears.
Get over your hill and see what you find there.
With grace in your heart and flowers in your hair.
In the absence of storm, we run and run as the rains come.
And I look up, I look up.
On my knees and out of love, I look up.
The night has always pushed away.
You must know life to seek and pay, but I won't rise.
I won't rise.
Not this mind and not this heart, I won't rise.
And I took you by the hand and we stood tall.
And we remembered our own land when we lived far.
And there will come a time you'll see.
With no more tears in love, I will not break your heart,
but dismiss your fears.
Get over your hill and see what you find there.
With grace in your heart and flowers in your hair,
there will come a time you'll see.
With no more tears in love, I will not break your heart,
but dismiss your fears.
Get over your hill and see what you find there.
With grace in your heart and flowers in your hair.
Thanks, Maggie and Mindy and Melody.
That was beautiful.
Great song to close out the message with.
Thank you so much for being here with us tonight.
Your presence makes our community just more Christlike
and beautiful and rich in all the ways that matter.
So thank you.
Thank you for being here.
Also, I just want to remind you about our meetups.
We have the teen group meeting this Wednesday
and the adult pandemic support group also meeting this Wednesday.
There's a link in the comments if you'd like more information
about these two meetups or the other meetups that we offer.
Just click on that link, put in your information.
We'd love to tell you more about those.
Also, you know, just right now during this time,
there are so many people in the Sachse, Garland, Dallas
and surrounding areas that are food insecure
and have very tight food budgets.
One of the organizations that we partner with is called
Five Lobes Food Pantry located in Sachse.
And if you are a current recurring giver to the table,
then a portion of your giving goes to Five Lobes.
We do partner with them.
But if you would like to give to Five Lobes directly,
you can see their website right there on the screen.
They're doing really, really good work in our area,
giving very tangibly to those in need.
They're a very worthy organization,
and we hope you'll consider giving to them.
So as we close out, I want to close with this blessing and benediction.
So while the darkness has this hour right now,
just remember and may the Lord bless you and protect you.
May the Lord make his face shine upon you.
May the Lord look with favor on you and give you peace.
You are loved and you are not alone.
Be blessed, and we hope to see you back here next week.
Bye-bye.
.